this morning we have an update on a
story about love and loyalty shown by
customers of a Southern California donut
shop but a year ago we showed you how
one of its owners became seriously ill
and her neighbors in a little surf town
spread the word on social media and it
made all the difference John Blackstone
returned to donut City to see how the
sweetness of strangers paid off what a
Christmas present to see you back here
oh yes Stella Chan is back behind the
counter at donut City in Seal Beach
California for nearly 30 years Stella
and her husband John have been a team
selling sweet treats and she brings
smiles to everyone's faces and they're
just just super loving people last year
there was doubt Stella would even
survive let alone return to work after a
debilitating brain aneurysm left her
partially paralyzed and unable to speak
now he's stronger stronger but with his
wife in a coma last year John came to
work each morning at 4 a.m. alone then
some of their regulars offered to help
what ISA hi she does we tried to offer
him money to help with the medical
expenses with Stella and he just
wouldn't accept you didn't want people
to just give you a dog no John would not
accept a handout so his customers
decided to try by turning to social
media they spread the word to show up
early and buy all of the donuts
so John could close up early and spend
more time with Stella
I'm kidding five dozen donuts take care
of the staff today at my kids elementary
school donuts were selling like hotcakes
people from 50 60 70 miles
they came here not only divided just one
doughnut but dozens they didn't even
want a doughnut but they came here and
helped it wasn't just people from Seal
Beach or close by
no other stay other country did all of
that support has that helped you get
better with Stella's return business is
back to a normal pace but the
confections now come with special
affection I feel grateful they gave me a
hot I'm so happy and the hole in this
doughnut shop has been filled with
kindness when you come in here and see
Stella behind the counter doughnut
city's complete a twinkle in my eyes a
delicious doughnut in my belly and the
day is good Wow Stella looks good I want
those doughnuts look pretty good too we
have it on good authority from producer
Robin singer that they are delicious
yes Tony I wanted to lick the teething
scrap but I thought that would be please